men compare women to cars all the time
ladies you the exact opposite of a car
your car is quiet it's running great
your girlfriend's quiet you're in deep
right
girlfriends and cars have nothing in
common except for the fact that my last
one was stolen by a black guy
I think men are more like cars ladies
you're more like horses Beautiful
Creatures long legs ponytail and
expensive to feed you always need new
shoes we slap you on the ass and once we
see it take a the Magic's over but
I think you can tell you're getting
closer with your lady when she starts
farting around you a lot I think that's
really the true test and I get it ladies
it's a biological function but can we
keep it under 10 a day what do you think
you just don't want that to become your
thing you're at a party who rip one
classic Claire
every time farting for a woman is like
crying for a man we all pretend to be
open-minded but that shit's a bummer
like the other day I was going down on
her she farted I started crying
she was like oh you need a tissue I was
like do you